en tunisie chine adhère à cash a annoncé
sa démission du poste de chef du cabinet
présidentiel à nouveau coup dur pour le
président tunisien plus jamais isolée
depuis son coup de force du 25 juillet
lé précision avec notre correspondante à
tunis sa basse et chemise elle était
inconnu du grand public mais cette
émission fait plus que jamais parlé des
nadja cash à l'une des plus proches
collaboratrices de cailly sayyed a fini
par jeter l'épongé lundi évoquant des
divergences profondes de point de vue en
relation avec la politique menée par le
locataire du palais de carthage une
annonce faite sur sa page facebook sans
plus de commentaire écoutez après deux
ans de travail j'ai décidé de
démissionner de mon poste en tant que
chef du cabinet présidentiel
puis les divergences profondes relatives
à cette responsabilité il est de mon
devoir de me retirer de ce poste docteur
en droit public spécialiste du droit
constitutionnel avait été nommé en 2019
chef du département des affaires
juridiques à la présidence de carthage
avant d'être propulsé au rang de chef de
cabinet de kaïs sayed un poste qu'elle
aurait perçu comme un lot de consolation
elle qui briguait le portefeuille de
l'intérieur un ministère qu'elle n'a
cessé de convoiter allant jusqu'à
s'opposer fermement à toutes les
décisions de l'actuel ministre de
l'intérieur taoufik écharpe et dean
selon des sources concordantes et
confirmée par l'ancien ambassadeur
américain en tunisie gordon gray dans un
article publié par nos confrères de
reuters nadja akasha était contre la
décision du ministre de l'intérieur de
mettre en retraite forcée six hauts
responsables dont un ancien chef du
renseignement tunisien et le recours
également à la répression par les forces
de l'ordre observée lors des
manifestations du 14 janvier dernier
dans la capitale tunisienne une des
missions de plus qui vient contredire le
décret présidentiel publié ce mardi au
journal officiel de la république
tunisienne indiquant que le président
sayyed a déminé nadja akasha de ses
fonctions de chef de cabinet après deux
ans de loyaux services